et nous sommes avec louis keumayou
président du club de l'information
africaine mais françois costantini
géopolitologue bonsoir messieurs et
merci d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte
france
est ce que c'est un véritable retrait de
la france du sahel est ce que vous y
voyez plus clair après les prises de
parole aujourd'hui d'emmanuel macron
françois constantini et on va vous poser
cette question avoue week-end maillot on
est en train de faire quelques réglages
avec françois costantini qu'est ce que
vous pensez des récentes déclarations d'
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui concernant
ce retrait de la france du sahel est ce
que c'est un vrai retrait pour vous non
je crois que la france ne veut pas
partir du 17 avec un arrière goût
d'inachevé avec avec un retrait qui
aurait des allures d'échelle par rapport
à la mission qu'elle s'est fixée on a
entendu un préalable avant la volonté
des manuels ma banque était de maintenir
une partie de l'armée française sur
place
en attendant ce retraites semble
opération avec l'armée malienne en
raison du coup d'état qui s'était
produit dans le pays et d etde volonté
de dialogue
ce nouveau régime avait avec les
certaines personnes aient déposé par la
france comme des djihadistes et je pense
que le plénum a provoqué un paquet il
veut à la fois sortir la france par le
haut de ce conflit et puis sortir
également la france 2 ce qui lui est
reproché le plus c'est à dire le fait
qu'ils aient beaucoup de bases
militaires françaises
un port dans l'ancien pré carré il a
déjà fait la faim du français phare en
afrique de l'ouest
je pense que le deuxième volet de cette
du ce retrait de la france des pays
africains d'afrique de l'ouest
ce serait le retrait des bases
militaires françaises mais je crois que
la france ne partira pas définitivement
à ce que la sécurité du sahel s'est
aussi d'une certaine manière la sécurité
de l'europe à ce que les menaces qui
sont présentes aujourd'hui dans le sel
pourrait également se retrouver au
niveau de la france et de l'europe
c'est pour cette raison que la france
est intervenue elle était parvenue pour
préserver ses intérêts dans cette région
et vous préservez également la secure
l'europe dans sa frontière sud en
méditerranée on vous a trouvé france à
constantine et on est ravi qu est-ce que
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
ces annonces avaient manuel macro sur ce
retrait annoncé avec ses premières bases
militaires dans le nord du mali qui
fermeront d'ici la fin d'année c'est ce
cas c'est ce qu'a déclaré emmanuel
macron une fermeture qui répond je cite
à la nécessité de s'adapter à la
nouvelle posture des groupes terroristes
d'accompagner aussi la prise de
responsabilité des pays de la région
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
ça suppose en effet que l'on a
aujourd'hui le terroriste qui tend à se
répandre
dire que la france est intervenue dans
une configuration particulière fin 2012
2013 avec l'opération barkan c'est à
dire qu'elle est intervenu alors qu'il y
avait une offensive contre l'état malien
sur une offensive terrestre tangible
identifiable sur le terrain là cette
fois ci la situation est quelque peu
différente parce que en effet dans les
faits des groupes jihadistes qui se
répandent a même qui utilisent les tous
les concepts de la guerre civile en se
répandant dans la population en prenant
la population en otage et mme également
fait également grave c'est qu'on a une
avancée des groupes à partir de ceux de
ce que j'appelle un petit peu cette
cette configuration l'aérosol le fait
que les groupes se répondent
on a une avancée vers le golfe de guinée
on sait que le bénin est menacée et puis
surtout un pays clé quand même qui est
là la côte d'ivoire qui tapait qui a été
passablement déstabilisé depuis une
quinzaine d'années a été touchée puisque
il ya eu la mort de cinq soldats qui a
dû être qui a été déploré il ya une
dizaine de jours donc on sait que cette
stratégie correspond en quelque sorte à
redéploiement 1a a en quelque sorte une
volonté d'en déployer une nouvelle
tactique mais certains en réduisant la
voilure mais il faudra penser également
à plus à plus d'appuis et peut-être plus
de solidarité internationale
on sait en effet que les états unis par
exemple son solo situation notamment
pour des missions d'appui de
ravitaillement au bois en vol et de et
de logistique est-ce que ce soit les
forces spéciales européennes les armées
locales louis qu'à mayotte qui vont
prendre le relais pour contenir les
violences
j'ai à dire c'est ce qu'ils en ont les
capacités aujourd'hui non c'est à dire
quel que soit le volume de soldats qui
seront envoyés
qu'il s'agisse de soldats français où
nos soldats ne m
je pense qu'ils ne seront jamais
suffisant ou contenir la menace
jihadiste dans cette région qui quand
même aussi grande
l'europe occidentale donc c'est mille
soldats ou 10 lille ça restera encore
une goutte d'eau dans dans ce marécage
de ce problème et donc il est important
que les pays eux-mêmes arrive à trouver
un moyen de coopération entre 2 et andy
que la menace les partenaires techniques
et partenaires bilatéraux ou
multilatéraux qui viendront nous
viendrons qu'en plus des efforts qui
seront fournis et qui seront
probablement meilleur si tous ces pays
là arrivé à coordonner leurs actions à
faire des actions transfrontalières en
indiqué le président du niger parce que
c'est ça la principale difficulté si on
chasse les médias disent dans un pays et
qu'ils peuvent trouver refuge dans un
autre pays sans client droite poursuit
au delà de la frontière du pays
donc qu'ils en fuite je pense que ce
sera sans objet
c'est pas des échanges d'informations
entre les différents termes et pour
savoir à quel moment pour moi cela
poursuit au moins on cerne les
différentes forces concernées se serait
également sans intérêt et aussi au delà
de ce périmètre du g5 celle que je n'ai
jamais trouvé pertinent la volonté
d'associer tous les pays sont concernés
par la menace
il faut que le sénégal il faut que le
bénin la côte d'ivoire le maroc
d'algérie
tous ces pays qui sont concernés par la
menace djihadiste prennent leur part et
donc au delà de la volonté de voir la
france et l'union européenne prennent
leur responsabilité il faudrait d'abord
que les armées africaines les armées des
pays riverains de la mnef prennent les
leurs et créatures en complément venant
de la france de l'europe ou des
nations-unies
pourquoi pas ce sera un plus tu seras
simplement des saisies mais pas le point
de départ de l'action militaire pour
qu'on comprenne bien
françois costantini comment est-ce que
cette opération de retrait des forces
françaises
va-t-elle tout elle modifier le rapport
de force sur le terrain ont trop les
armées régulières et les djihadistes
qu'ils soient liés à al-qaïda ou groupe
etat islamique
on peut pas encore prêt juste préjugés 1
puisque on l'annoncé faite qu'il y
aurait un retrait fin 2020 fin 2021
début 2022 pour passer environ 2 de 5000
ha ha ha 3000 3500 hommes
donc on peut pas au viol en effet sur le
terrain de ce que seront les conditions
il est certain qu'après son dg à dist
est extrêmement fort c'est comme me le
disait en effet il faudrait il faut
élargi en effet le g5 sel même si on est
au départ le g5 c'est là toute sa
pertinence dans l'association aca france
notamment dans là dans la formation à 1
je pense également de l'apport de
certains pays on sait claude jade à une
des très bonnes armes et combattante et
la mort tragique du président et disent
des bijoux a été un as a été un coup
très dur qui a été portée à la lutte
contre contre le dire contre le
djihadisme mais en effrayer fera les
registres un pays comme le maroc en
effet joue un rôle essentiel dans la
lutte contre contre le terrorisme ne pas
oublier comme les racines de cette
déstabilisation qui vient de l'opération
calamiteuses menées en 2011 en libye et
qui a mis les construit quand ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya également
des dépressions qui viennent de groupes
de libye on sait qu'aujourd'hui vous
faire quitter la libye à 25 mille
mercenaires à peu près donc bonne
partition de sonder les sons des
djihadistes et remettent l'arrêt ce 6e
ceci ne fait qu'accroître le danger en
effet sur le sel et sur disons de façon
générale tout l'ouest africain puisque
en effet c'est la guinée qui est qui et
toucher etc et on peut on pourrait même
craindre si le jazz n'est pas contenue
peut-être une une convergence annonce
avoir avec l'afrique l'afrique tropicale
avec la fir est que voir vers l'afrique
centrale puisque le carolo cameroun
finalement ce n'est pas si éloigné que
sort
le nigeria non plus quand on voit des
pays notamment qui sont touchés par par
boko haram
il ya une crainte en effet de voir ces
groupes pas faire une jonction général
mais du moins commencer à à à connaître
une certaine coordination entre eux donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait qu'il faut
mais il faut à mon sens associer le plus
grand nombre d'états africains et puis
également de façon générale impliqué de
façon peut-être plus visible l'union
africaine et vous rejoignez enfin oui
que mayo louis vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure cette discussion qui sont donc
nés fait fer entre les états il faut
associer les pays et qui sont concernés
par la menace djihadiste plusieurs états
africains appellent eux aussi aux
négociations avec les groupes armés
paris l'exclu ce que son retrait peu
d'eau ne peut changer la donne avec
quelles conséquences ça ce sera
malheureusement loin de la fin parce que
le temps file d'anglais interdit au pays
de négocier avec des citoyens parce que
ce sont d'abord des ressortissants de
ces villes sont concernées
ils ont pris un chemin qui n'est pas
celui d'un logo on ne peut pas
l'encourager mais si on était tout le
monde sur le rang du terrorisme
je crains malheureusement qu'il n'y ait
pas grand monde pour discuter il y en a
qui devront être condamnés ne doit pas
être la règle
en revanche on ne doit pas fermer la
porte du dialogue quand ce dialogue
blaye possible
l'une des initiatives avaient été menées
dans ce sens ce soit désavantagé elle
est signée pour régler la question du
nord du mali quand je crois qu'on ne
doit pas de fermer la porte et surtout
la france doit apporter sonné sort donné
l'impression de vouloir imposer la
manière du résoudre le problème obi qui
sont concernés par la menace de façon
merci beaucoup louis keumayou président
du club de l'information africaine merci
à vous également froisse françois
costantini géopolitologue merci d'avoir
participé à cet échange ce soir
messieurs et à bientôt sur rt france